.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: I THINK I HAVE GOOD NEWS
FOR YOU TWO.
DAMON FISHER TELLS ME THIS IS
YOUR LAST SEGMENT, WHICH MEANS
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN, THIS IS
YOUR LAST SEGMENT OF THE ENTIRE
NBA SEASON.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: I THOUGHT THAT WOULD MAKE
YOU HAPPY.
KENNY: WE ARE OFFICIALLY DONE.
THIS IS TWO YEARS STRAIGHT OF
BASKETBALL.
I LOVE THE GAME.
PUT SOME PANTS ON, SHAQ.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE: KENNY AND SHAQ, ENJOY
YOUR OFF-SEASON.
IT HAS BEEN A RUN FOR YOU GUYS.
KENNY: IT HAS BEEN A LOT OF FUN.
IT IS BITTER AND SWEET.
YOU FINISH, BUT YOU WANT TO SEE
HOW IT ENDED.
YOU WANT TO BE PART OF THAT.
SO I DO KIND OF MISS THE FACT I
WILL NOT BE PART OF IT, BUT I
WON'T MISS IT LONG.
ISIAH: ARE YOU TIRED FROM THEM
JUMPING JACKS?
SHAQ: I'M TIRED AS HELL.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, I LOVE YOU
GUYS, YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I LOVE
YOU, ISIAH STEVE,, KENNY.
I WILL SEE YOU IN OCTOBER.
MATT: YOU'VE GOT ALL SUMMER TO
BUY SOME PANTS.
SHAQ: MATT, IN THE WORDS OF
CHRIS TUCKER, DON'T WORRY ABOUT
WHAT I'M GOING TO BE DOING.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: BON VOYAGE, FELLAS.
ENJOY THE REST OF THIS SUMMER.
[LAUGHTER]